>>Student: I got it high.
>>Eric: Oh yeah, nice.
>>Narrator: In rural Grants Pass,
Oregon, Eric Epstein uses games
to teach students at Jerome
Prairie Elementary School,
better social skills.
>>Eric: Okay, so first of all, who
remembers something you learned
from medicine ball,
that helped you succeed?
Yes?
>>Student: Teamwork.
>>Eric: Teamwork, okay.
>>Your job now is to make a
creature, a living creature
out of your play dough that
represents you in some way.
>>Narrator: Epstein works
for the nonprofit Southern
Oregon Adolescent Study
and Treatment Center.
As a school community
advocate, he spends most
of his week with students.
>>Student: I made a gorilla as mine.
>>Eric: So why is the
gorilla like you?
>>Student: It's big and strong.
>>Eric: Big and strong.
Good.
>>Narrator: A key to the
advocate's success is
that they avoid the stigma
of formal counseling.
Running student clubs, they
become magnets for kids
who need a personal connection.
>>Eric: How is you guys' day going?
Are you surviving?
>>Narrator: Then, having
earned the students' trust,
they counsel children in crisis.
>>Eric: Is it, when Mom and Dad
are fighting, do you go hide
in your room, or what do you do,
so you don't have to hear it?
>>Narrator: Grants Pass
is a high poverty area
with many kids who need the help.
Across town, at North Valley High
School, Epstein deals with everything
from sexual abuse,
to drugs, to suicide.
>>Student: I got my heart broken,
and I didn't really think
there was much left to life,
so I just decided I'd try and end it.
It was a hard time
trying to get back.
I got a lot of help from you.
And it's getting easier
every day, but just barely.
>>Eric: There is no better access
point in America, for connecting
with kids and families,
than public school systems.
Most traditional counselors, most
of their time is in an office
that people have to come
to, in order to visit them.
If we are able to go and be alongside
them in life, they have more trust
that we can understand their
life, and we generally do.
>>Student: I kind of freaked
people out with what I did.
I got really mad for not really any
particular reason, and you know,
I hit a locker, and my hand
was bleeding everywhere.
[Playing guitar].
>>Linda: For adolescents,
it's their peer relationships
that are more important than anything
else going on in their lives.
If we intervene separate from
those peer relationships,
we may learn some great
things about the student,
but we're not really hitting
it where the action is.
>>Eric: It's one thing to have a
passionate belief that you hold onto,
because you deeply believe in it,
and it's another, to become rigid
and to not be able to have
that belief affected by people.
>>Narrator: It costs
15,000 dollars a year
to have an advocate ten hours a
week, a price mainly paid by grants.
Discipline referrals have dropped
since the start of the program,
and educators here say
there are further rewards.
>>Ken: Well before Eric came to
our school, I had to be a counselor
to the students, and I
had to handle situations
that I really felt uncomfortable in.
When Eric came onboard, it was
nice, because I was spending,
probably 25 to 35 percent of my
time dealing with these situations,
and here is somebody who's a
professional, that has training
in this area, and better than
that, the kids will work with.
>>Student: Thanks for being there.
>>Eric: My pleasure.
>>Student: I guess the thing I
needed today, is you can't stand
up with your own two legs sometimes.
You need another pair.
Everyone does.
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.